[Música]
el grupo Wagner recula en su rebelión
contra la cúpula militar rusa después de
un acuerdo entre el líder de Los
mercenarios y el presidente ruso Nicolás
Maduro mandó su apoyo a Vladimir Putin
en Estados Unidos se cumple un año desde
que la Corte Suprema de drogara la
sentencia de versus White la
jurisprudencia que garantizaba el aborto
legal en todo el país desde entonces
decenas de Estados han prohibido o
restringido este derecho y el tema
vuelve a estar candente de Cara a las
elecciones de 2024
Guatemala va a las urnas este domingo
tres candidatos y lideran la intención
de Voto en una primera vuelta marcada
por la desafección política la
corrupción y la pobreza en el país los
principales aspirantes admiran el modelo
implementado por najibe bukele en El
Salvador
Bienvenidos a la pantalla de France 24 y
a este resumen de las noticias más
destacadas del continente americano Mi
nombre es Juan pupiales el presidente de
Venezuela Nicolás Maduro expresó su
apoyo a Vladimir Putin quien ha vivido
unas horas con bolsas al frente de Rusia
donde el líder del grupo Wagner
emprendió una rebelión contra la cúpula
militar que detuvo unas horas más tarde
tras un acuerdo mediado por el
presidente de belarus escuchemos las
palabras del presidente de Venezuela
todo nuestro abrazo de solidaridad y
apoyo al presidente de la federación
rusa al compañero Vladimir Putin que ha
sabido enfrentar un intento de traición
un intento de guerra civil y está a esta
hora a esta altura victorioso con Rusia
en paz desde Venezuela todo nuestro
apoyo al presidente Vladimir Putin
hermano de Venezuela y a continuación
les ofrecemos un repaso sobre la
historia del grupo Wagner
lleva el nombre del compositor favorito
de Hitler fundado y dirigido por Jeff y
gojin el grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner
juega hoy un papel importante en la
Guerra de Ucrania lejos de su Coto de
caza favorito África Sudán Libia Chad
Guinea y Madagascar según el centro de
estudios estratégicos internacionales
sus mercenarios están ahora presentes en
unos 15 países de todo el continente el
modelo africa ahora bien conocido la
depredación de los recursos locales a
cambio de sus servicios el resultado es
una enorme ganancia financiera
incalculable presencial para financiar
sus operaciones en Ucrania y para pagar
bien a sus hombres también presentes en
Siria y Venezuela Los mercenarios de
wagnes son acusados en varios países
africanos de violación y tortura desde
hace varios meses el grupo gana fuerza
en Ucrania
está perdiendo muchos hombres cada día
especialmente en batmut donde los
combates con el ejército ucraniano han
durado meses es imposible saber cuántos
hombres tiene Wagner porque decenas de
miles de prisioneros han sido reclutados
en la cárcel y otros tantos según su
líder murieron en el campo de batalla
Vladimir Putin ha negado durante mucho
tiempo la existencia del grupo y aún
niega cualquier vínculo con él en
noviembre pasado los paramilitares
finalmente salieron de las Sombras e
inauguraron este imponente edificio en
el corazón de San Petersburgo la ciudad
donde pregolín y Putin se conoci y que
alberga otra de las actividades de
Wagner su propaganda para el kremlin una
fábrica de trolls que emplea a miles de
soldados digitales el segundo ejército
de Jeff Jenny
en Estados Unidos hoy se cumple un año
desde que el tribunal supremo de hogar a
la sentencia de Ro versus White la
jurisprudencia que garantizaba el acceso
al aborto legal en todo el territorio
estadounidense coincidiendo con esta
fecha my pensé que compite por la
nominación del partido republicano
defendió ir todavía más lejos en la
limitación de este derecho
gracias a su trabajo y a sus oraciones
la Corte Suprema de Estados Unidos envió
a Row versus White al montón de cenizas
de la historia donde pertenece Y le dio
a Estados Unidos su nuevo comienzo para
la vida
pero mientras celebramos el progreso que
hemos logrado nos reunimos aquí sabiendo
que no Hemos llegado al final de esta
causa Hemos llegado al final del
principio y el trabajo por la vida
continúa en todo Estados Unidos
y Es que desde la derogación de Row
versus White 20 estados and restringido
el derecho al aborto una limitación que
en ciertos casos implica que las mujeres
que quieren interrumpir su embarazo
deben recorrer cientos de kilómetros o
poner en riesgo sus vidas en abortos
clandestinos
un año de una decisión que suprimió los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos de las
mujeres estadounidenses el 24 de junio
de 2022 la Corte Suprema de mayoría
conservadora anuló la sentencia del caso
Row versus White de 1973 que permitía a
las mujeres abortar libre y legalmente
desde entonces al menos 20 estados
tienen prohibiciones casi totales o
nuevas leyes que limitan el acceso a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
debido a estas restricciones Amanda
residente de Texas estuvo a punto de
morir por un aborto involuntario
es exasperante y dicen que lo hacen
porque son provida Pero no entiendo que
tiene esto de provida porque estuve a
punto de morir porque están en riesgo
las vidas de mis futuros bebés
con la nueva normativa cientos de
clínicas tuvieron que cerrar el personal
sanitario y los médicos de atención
materna de los estados restrictivos se
enfrentan a la disyuntiva de renunciar a
sus trabajos o ir nuestros estados por
miedo a ser condenados
los riesgos de ser acusado de un delito
grave los riesgos reales de prisión y
cómo se vería eso para mi familia y para
mi carrera y todo lo que habíamos
trabajado tan duro para construir
con la prohibición vigente ya no pudimos
brindar el estándar de atención la
medicina más basada en evidencia para
ciertas complicaciones del embarazo
Porque se consideró ilegal
Pese a que las activistas defensoras de
derechos humanos han alertado que este
retroceso en materia de derechos pone en
riesgo la vida de miles de mujeres los
grupos religiosos y conservadores
republicanos aspiran a más y buscan
prohibir también los métodos
anticonceptivos la píldora abortiva o
los viajes entre Estados para abortar
por ello el viernes el presidente Joe
biden firmó una nueva orden ejecutiva
para proteger el acceso anticonceptivos
entre otras cosas Las aseguradoras
privadas deberán cubrir la mayoría de
los costos de estos medicamentos
lo adelantábamos en titulares Guatemala
este domingo celebrar la primera vuelta
de las elecciones generales uno de los
retos cruciales al que se enfrentan los
candidatos es reducir la pobreza
el informe
cendi empleada doméstica en Guatemala
tiene claro un objetivo migrar en
diciembre hacia Estados Unidos
te decía que los guatemaltecos lo más
ideal es Buscar un coyote para irse así
ilegal
como ella cientos de miles de
guatemaltecos escapan cada año de la
pobreza a pesar de endeudarse en una
hazaña que cuesta 15 mil dólares
o tienen en mente sacar adelante la
familia especialmente la familia porque
aquí no no hay modo de salir adelante
con limpiezas y planchados se envíase
parte del 60% de los guatemaltecos que
ganan entre 100 y 200 dólares al mes muy
por debajo del salario mínimo
Don Carlitos
en materia de elecciones quien quede de
presidente la tiene sin cuidado Yo
siempre he dicho de que el presidente
que queda no le va a dar de comer a uno
quien lo ha intentado todo por ingresar
legalmente a Estados Unidos es Brian
Allá vive su mamá a quien no ve desde
hace 28 años
como su mamá en Estados Unidos hay cerca
de 4 millones de guatemaltecos quienes
mensualmente envían dinero a sus
familiares a través de remesas que te
digo yo no nunca si nunca pasa de ser
400 a lo mucho 500 dólares por lo de la
obra digamos
con el dinero que le llega Brian se
encuentra construyendo su casa un
privilegio en Guatemala como seres
humanos que vivimos en este país sobre
todo el ver que alguien está
construyendo su casa haciendo su casa es
una alegría o sea significativa digamos
verdad en el país centroamericano las
remesas familiares constituyen cerca del
20% del pib y mantienen estable la
economía de un país que batalla contra
la pobreza
y nos despedimos con imágenes de Ciudad
de México en el marco del mes del
orgullo la capital mexicana ha sido
escenario de una marcha multitudinaria
en defensa de los derechos del colectivo
lgbtiq más unos derechos que sobre todo
fuera de la gran ciudad son
sistemáticamente vulnerados con
impunidad según denuncian organizaciones
en defensa de los Derechos Humanos
con esas imágenes despedimos este
informativo la invitación es a ustedes
para que continúen aquí en France 24 y
también en Francia 24.com
[Música]